I don't know what's do you your family
your parents I don't know your you know
if your parents are around or not but
when they hear your music what do they
think oh my mom she she'd be turned up
she was like hell yeah yeah talk that
[__] yeah she be with it she know every
word that's amazing my dad he told me he
don't want to hear that I was gonna say
your dad though is the real yeah he he
he's happy for me like he's like oh I
hear your mom tells me like you're doing
this and that but he's like turn it up I
don't want to hear my daughter talking
about that like right has he been to a
show no yeah but then again my dad never
went to a soccer game oh but but shout
out to him though you got problems like
uh like dad issues a little bit I had
them in the past now I just know you got
over them yeah you say it's whatever
that's fair I respect that love him
though shout out to Paul shade shout out
to Pops yeah I always wonder like you
know like if you have a song like uh
some of your records like what's dad
think or does he can he listen no I
don't think he's ever listened you know
like I have like a you know there's like
girls who have like only fans accounts
and I just wonder if like their dad
knows or if their dad's friends know no
one time I my dad never seen my
Instagram and this is before like my mom
didn't approve like what I would be
posting on Instagram and so she caught
him was like
this is what your daughter posted on
Instagram so he was like I came in the
house one day and he was like sitting in
the chair like my dad is not serious at
all like I don't take him serious
whatsoever like I came in like laughing
like what are you doing he's like well
if you want to work for Playboy you know
not in my house and I'm just like Dad
leave me alone
like really what an old old dude
reference yeah like nobody yeah he's
they don't even have naked women in
Playboy anymore the magazine is ruined
forever it's like a glorified he made it
seem like it was a bad thing like matter
of fact actually tell Playboy hit me up
actually you're right I want to be here
to check hey and you don't even have to
take your clothes off to be in Playboy
that's what I'm saying he but he don't
know that he's just trying to be funny
and it just wasn't I was just like man
watching TV watch the TV for sure what's
the last show you uh binge watched
um the last show I binge watched was
this is the show called Sirens Sirens
this is about mermaids
nice it's actually a really good show
y'all should try to watch it on
um Hulu Sirens about mermaids yeah I
like stuff like that like when I'd be
going on through Tick Tock and the
people be like mermaids are real I I
like one of those videos I like I just
go down the whole of just like trying to
figure out if they're really real like I
have to get to the bottom of it I saw a
video uh that looked like it was
horseshit but uh one of my friends
reposted it like this is wild and it's
like a someone took it from the side of
a boat and like you could see like a I
kind of see like a mermaid come in and
out of the water and I was like bruh but
he really he believed it yeah people
were people people in Jamaica like they
tell you like the mermaids are there
like it's a I forgot what it's called
but it's like a
a lake or something and so you think
mermaids are real yeah
I believe it how do they breathe
well we don't know you know I
should not even Discover it so how we
can't even go down to the bottom so am I
right so I'm sure it's plenty things we
don't know about so uh my mom's uncle
was one of the first employees at NASA
he died his name's Uncle doc rest in
peace
my mom asked him if aliens were real
this was like in the 90s she asked them
and he can't say [__] because I guess
his whole life is monitored but he said
I can't say that but what I will say is
if most people knew what was in the
ocean they'd want to kill themselves
yeah
that's why that's my biggest fear like I
don't get on cruise ships I can't see
land also because you have some class
nobody wants to go on a [__] cruise
ship if you have class yeah no yeah true
but it's like that's my biggest fear
because that's in the middle in the
middle of the water with a bunch of yeah
it's a bunch of Amazon employees oh my
God eating all-inclusive meals how we
like the all-inclusive though me too
never too real but never too of course
that's why I like going to Cancun you go
to Cancun I've never been to Cancun
no so where do you get inclusive at I
went to Jamaica I got all inclusive it
was bomb I stayed on the overwater
Bungalows [__]
no my man was rich